[Music]
previously on x-men and what this made
me really think about was the fact that
there's just so much about the human
body so much that we're capable of that
we just don't train and so in this video
I'm going to share some of the most
interesting options for increasing your
strength and performance that you might
not have considered and that many people
overlook work capacity is basically
cardio fitness but in the context of
whatever form of exercise it is you're
interested in doing this is one of the
main thing
another reason you might have to stop
doing pull-ups though or feel like
you're exhausted is because you're just
not breathing and as you well know
breathing is important but it's easy to
forget about breathing when you're
lifting something really heavy
however breathing correctly or using the
right breathing techniques can actually
help you to perform better so it's
really important that we do this and
especially during cardio again it all
just comes down to being conscious and
thinking about what you're doing rather
than just letting it happen so how do
you breathe properly during your
training normally you will breathe out
during the exertion and you'll breathe
in during the easy part and that
normally means breathing out during the
concentric phase and breathing in during
the eccentric phase so that means that
say you're doing curls you'll breathe
out as you pull them up and breathe in
as they go back down this is something
grants been picking me up on during my
martial arts training because I tend to
hold my breath around punching whereas
exhaling during a punch can actually
help you to exert a lot more strength
this is of course why we have the Kea in
martial arts the spirit shout or one
reason we have it because it helps us to
focus more energy and at the same time
not hold our breath it's also important
how you breathe when you're breathing
doing exercise you should be belly
breathing you should always be very
breathing that means that you're using
your diaphragm and your transverse
abdominal provide the oxygen rather than
your chest things get a little bit
different when you're lifting a really
heavy amount of weight in which case you
might brace yourself and that means
you're holding a breath in this specific
kind of way in order to give yourself
even more rigidity even more support to
do this you might use the valsalva
technique and this is basically
breathing out but not letting any air
out so you're bracing and contracting
but you're not breathing outwards and
this can help you to prevent injury and
exert more strength you just have to
build up to it again try not to pass out
or burst a blood-vessel I'm gonna talk
more about this in future again and yes
I am gonna cover things like the wim HOF
method which allow you to control your
sympathetic nervous system here's
another area that's massively overlooked
that is just fascinating and that's your
foot strength and your foot mobility so
most of us wear shoes most of the time
and that essentially completely negates
the potential power of our feet
our feet contain 25 percent of all the
bones in our body and that should tell
you that they do something pretty
important not only do your feet allow
you to push off of the ground at
different angles they allow you to
ground yourself and anchor yourself more
thereby giving yourself better purchase
any martial artist knows that if you
throw a good punch it should start with
the feet you generate the power from the
floor equal and opposite force and all
that so if you aren't properly connected
to the ground
you're not going to maximize the amount
of force you can push through your arms
and that goes for other movements too at
the same time though your feet are also
incredibly important proprioceptive
tools so they provide you with feedback
about the ground and that helps to
prevent yourself from tipping over from
twisting your ankle at the same time
your feet can move the muscles and the
flexibility allowed them to contour to
the shape of the floor which prevents
you from twisting your ankle or just
falling over and like I say we are
heating up plantar fascia essentially
dead because we keep them trapped and
locked in these shoes all day long one
commenter on the bio near put me on to
the channel of Chong Zhi called the
secret of athleticism and that channel
is all about the importance of what he
calls the hyper arch mechanism so this
is the ability to control the shape of
your foot and thereby engage your glutes
more in exercise so he talks about the
importance of training the strength in
the foot and the arch in particular
because that allows you to generate the
power from the glutes which makes you
able to jump fast jump higher run faster
and generally perform as a superior
athlete so what can you do to improve
your foot mobility and strength well one
obvious thing is to run barefoot or
using minimal shoes such as the Vibram
FiveFingers
do again build up to this slowly that
goes for everything on this list don't
just rush into it because you can damage
your knee if you start sprinting around
on concrete barefoot you need to
gradually ease yourself into it an
easier method is just to train in the
gym barefoot and more people do this and
help them to prevent injury and even
increase the there max lifts you can
also obviously do this out
that's even better and your garden or
out in nature another thing you can do
is to roll out the fascial on the foot
by rolling a golf ball or a tennis ball
on it golf ball better harder is better
at the same time you can use exercises
such as Qiong C's hyper arch hopping and
this basically involves hopping on your
toes and keeping your foot in that
locked arched position so heel is raised
off the ground so you can generate more
power that way and you should feel your
glutes working interestingly this is
something that Shaolin monks have been
doing for a long time and on that
channel he points out that they will
often perform things like horse stance
on these poles and not only is that
training their balance but it's also
digging the pressure into the feet to
enforce them to engage the glutes more
rather than the quads little brings us
nicely onto the concept of faster so in
a very recent video I talked about
fashion I recommend you check that out
if you're interested
and basically fashio is this connective
tissue a kind of sheet that covers all
the muscles all the joints and it
actually isn't just this inert stuff not
only is it a sport structure but it
might also aid with communication
between nerves and at the same time it
might also have its own Meccano
receptors so it can help with
proprioceptive and at the same time
saying smooth muscle tissue so it has
contractile properties and because the
fashio is a single sheet that covers the
entire body
that's why releasing the tension in your
soles of your feet can actually improve
your mobility throughout your entire
body and what's also really interesting
is that this might also explain why
Shaolin monks are capable of some of the
incredible stuff that we see them do
like take bricks to the face without
wincing
and throw pins through sheets of glass
because they're concentrating those
parts of the body and using their entire
bodies a single unit generating power
from the feet all the way through to the
hands or hardening parts of the body to
the point that they can take these
incredible blows
martial justice souter they're so soft
but besides Sodom the periodical Derrick
I'm out now remember the way to vision
tackle it is ambidexterity so
ambidexterity is something that i've
always been interested in training it's
one of the things that originally got me
started on this road to training unusual
stuff I've written posts on the bar near
about I've made an old video but I'm
sure to come back to it soon training
ambidexterity can obviously improve your
general dexterity by allowing you to use
both hands and potentially both legs
equal it can build your contralateral
strength and performance helping you to
utilize other parts of your body due to
the way that they're all connected and
it might even increase your creativity
by thickening the corpus callosum making
your brain more like Einsteins and of
course for a martial artist it helps you
to fight both the southpaw and Orthodox
if you're lifting weights in the gym
then it can help you to improve your
symmetry in terms of the aesthetic sand
also you performance by helping you to
exert equal strength on both sides and
yeah there's lots of ways you can train
your ambidexterity there's ways you can
do it in the gym by making sure to
really control the weights with both
limbs at the same time you can also just
practice writing with both hands and
this is something you can do by
incidental training say for instance if
you write to journal then why not each
day write that journal with your other
hand or write the last couple of
sentences with the other hand there's
other things you can do too like
brushing your teeth with the other hand
or if you kick a ball around try kicking
that with your other foot etc and of
course when doing heavy bag work it can
pay off to simply switch stance and
throw punches from the other side for a
bit so the savvy among you might be
wondering where the writing of your left
hand is gonna make you ambidextrous
across all skills or if it's gonna just
make you better at writing with your
left
and the answer is basically probably
both things are true to some extent so
on the one hand there are definitely
skills you can develop more with one
hand than the other simply by training
them and there are certain things that
you do with your left hand more often
that you're wholly better at doing even
now with your left hand for instance if
you play a guitar and you'll find that
making chord shapes with your right hand
and using the fretboard is more
difficult because you've trained that
with the left hand but at the same time
I'm sure that a complex skill such as
writing with your left hand will
generally improve your mind muscle
connection with that hand the dexterity
and your ability to use fine motor
control and finally that brings us to
the last tool that I think lots could
benefit from adding to their training
and that's overcoming isometrics so
overcoming isometrics simply means
pulling or pushing against an immovable
force that means 100% effort with zero
movement you might be trying to push
down a wall pull down a tree like the
Indian wrestle of gamma or bend an iron
bar or rip the rope in half all these
things mean you're trying to use a
hundred percent of your effort and
thereby you're able to increase your
neurological link with your muscles your
ability to recruit two muscle fibers
because most of us can only recruit
around 30 percent of our muscle fiber
elite athletes might be able to recruit
up to fifty percent that means there's a
lot of untapped strength and this is
simply an example of specific
adaptations to impose demands if you
practice trying to use a hundred cent of
your strength then your brain will
become better at doing so and we see
this with strongmen and old-time
strongmen they practice this kind of
thing a lot and as a result they're
capable of performing some incredible
feats I've talked about overcoming
isometrics a lot and how you can utilize
it in your training so I'm going to in
depth here again the one tip something I
haven't talked about before you can try
is to put yourself in a position where
you're doing overcoming isometric so
take a bar and try and bend it or try
and push down a wall then exert maximum
effort for about five seconds six
seconds and then you should find that
you start to lose strength you're not
pushing or pulling as hard as you
normally would
then give yourself an extra burst of
speech and accelerate into again and
just say I'm gonna do one more burst of
strength and what you'll find is you
accrue more muscle again you're capable
of generating more muscle than you
thought you were and that's an example
of how it's in your mind and how it's
all about the neural dry
and this is a really good way of
training at Newell Drive so you're
reminding yourself to focus on really
engaging that muscle we also see this in
the bilateral deficit that's the
observation that were capable of
generating more strength when we use one
leg than we only use both legs at the
same time so for instance if you were to
do the leg press
you could probably push more than 50% of
your one rep max with one of your legs
and the reason for this is because
you're focusing a hundred percent of
your effort and attention on that one
limb rather than dividing it by two and
again this shows how the neural drive is
so important and in general just making
sure to be more aware of your body and
how you're using it when you perform the
movement and this is really what we've
been looking at with a lot of these
different training methods and
techniques basically we're looking at
controlling our bodies more and being
more aware of different parts of our
body we're looking at recruiting more
muscle fiber also looking at being more
aware of our body and how rigid it is
when we're performing an exercise and
how we're generating power from the
ground we're looking at building up this
more supported muscle so we can
incorporate them into our training we're
basically using the body as a more
cohesive and single unit and a lot of
our modern training programs don't allow
us to do this because they focus on
individual parts of the body and they
miss out things like the serratus
muscles like straight arm strength like
grip strength like the feet and we've
lost a lot of the strength a lot of the
skills that would have had naturally
from training in the wild but if we look
at these examples of individuals who've
managed to get some of that back and if
we then apply our scientific
understanding it was to use those
concepts more efficiently and understand
why they're working then we can not only
regain some of our lost strength and
performance we can potentially go beyond
nature thanks Sam for watching guys hope
vans pretty useful interesting if you
did then please leave like please
subscribe to the channel and comment
down below all those things helped me
out immensely and I love your comments
and your suggestions they feel a lot of
the content in these videos I've got
lots more coming up in the near future
I'm going to be looking at Bruce Lee the
myth vs. the reality I'm gonna be
looking at a realistic Batman style
training routine that you could fit into
a regular person's life style
incorporating a lot of these ideas I'm
going to be looking at accelerated
learning and how you can use the
internet to help with that I'm gonna be
looking at how to analyze a study
clothes that help to enhance your
performance and we've got the first
video from Grant on range of motion on
how to improve your flexibility so if
that all sounds good then thanks a ton
for watching stay tuned and I'll see you
next time
bye for now